[Music]
last night was the world premiere of
solo a Star Wars story and they shut
down Hollywood Boulevard for the big
event I mean how else would you be able
to park the Millennium Falcon what's
your reaction is boom is my reaction to
this
how did they get that here seriously cuz
it's really big and it's like right in
the middle of Hollywood which can't be
cheap I'm guessing a solo mission that
put a Hollywood at a standstill massive
premiere caps off an equally epic read
for the film's co-star John Glover it
started hosting SNL yes I am Danny
Glover's father the release of this
politically charged music video this is
America it has nearly 80 million YouTube
views in less than a week but this is
definitely a highlight captain Lindo
Carosi on soil on the carpet Glover
posed alongside Billy Dee Williams who
originally played Lando the film's
breakout star Alden Ehrenreich play solo
a role that also made Harrison Florida
star compare this experience with your
first movie premiere the first movie of
Romero is a movie called tetro I don't
think they let me into the party
my name is 19 and I was like trust me
I'm supposed to be in the party you
don't get into tonight's party I mean
there's some serious problem and there's
some serious screening really didn't go
out
[Music]
[Applause]